des amateurs de glisse
hier si c'est le moment vérité te plante
s'est bâti
je ne peux pas m'en empêcher
[Applaudissements]
alors que ton oncle harold et moi
cherchions la hamster des ténèbres c'est
quoi ça
trouver c'est la plus belle chose
retient qui me soit jamais arrivée
génial tout le monde va nous voir avec
cette espèce de poules et lapins celle
où tout le monde se moque de moi papa
si je rapporte le hamster des ténèbres
qui finiront tous par m'accepter
rien cassé et vous cherchez un guide je
m'appelle mail suivez moi il vous
arrivera rien
oh non ça c'est ballot va devoir rentrer
chez nous maintenant
seul qui va accéder au temple wat
abordés nous trois épreuves mortelles
pourrait ne pas s'arrêter à deux
épreuves mortelles
j'aime en france ne bouge pas on est
tous nés avec quelque chose de différent
les amateurs de glisse
mais on peut décider que ce qui nous
rend différents nous rend aussi
exceptionnelle
oh c'est contré
laplante a déjà vu voler ta disait non à
vous et je vole pas
tu vois je vole pas